hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd unboxing video and in this one i'm
going to be unboxing something that is
going to be become a very big part of my
youtube channel from here on out this is
something you're going to be seeing or
hearing from in all the rest of my
hardware related videos and if you
haven't guessed it or read it already
yes this is the unboxing of my new hd
camcorder the sanyo xacti cg10
so let's just get right on into this
guys i am using the microphone quality i
actually already dug into this uh
because my knife does take a while to
open but i i'm i'm using the quality of
the microphone of the uh
the camera you're seeing right now uh
just for a comparison so that when i do
some uh test footage with this new
camcorder you guys be able to see and
hear the quality difference
so here's the actual uh packaging box
as you can see it is advertised highly
as a dual camera i will of course
include the links to everything you need
to know about this camera in the
description so uh let's just get right
on into uh the actual packaging so i can
show you guys what's in the box and
we'll uh see what's what's good from
here so here we go
so you'll notice right on top is a lot
of paper and i'll get this all out for
you guys this is all in one language i
believe um actually this is not english
so here you go there's a whole lot of
paper really not much you need to read
some instruction manuals some safety
instructions and a really big booklet
about the software so let's get right
into the hardware
so i'll unpack everything before the
camera so right here we have a little
lanyard for the lens cap which makes
sense
we have our av cables to the usb
we have the usb to proprietary usb for
the sanyo camera
as we keep going
we have the battery charging so here we
have
what we plug into the uh the cord which
plugs into the wall i kind of would have
preferred a little flip out cord and
just plug it straight into the wall
something where i would have been able
to use the camcorder while it's charging
but i'd actually don't mind this this is
what i have with my current camera setup
keep going we'll find the actual battery
which is very similar to the battery
we're using on the camera you're
watching from
which is by the way an olympus fe 370.
here's the actual sanyo exactly lens
clip little handy thing definitely want
to protect the most important part of
the camera the lens
and that looks like about it and here is
the camera itself
so it is a handheld camera
the most important statistics really are
that it does shoot in 720p hd at 30
frames a second and 60 frames a second
vga resolution and takes 10 megapixel
photos so here it is guys it's a really
nice size i really like this here you
see all the navigation buttons i'll be
getting into these in the review video
and there's your lens so of course i'll
be putting the lens cap on this uh very
soon there's the flash for the 10
megapixel photos
and a big part of the camera that i will
be looking at whenever i shoot
the three inch lcd and that's actually a
lot bigger than i thought it was it's 16
by nine and this of course will be
shooting in a mpeg-4 format
inside here is your power button and
inside over here is where you can throw
in that sd slot which is actually in the
mail right now from newegg so that's
that's just a brief unboxing and i'll
definitely have some uh some sample
footage for you guys in one of the
coming videos and i'm really excited to
get to use this camera but anyway this
has been an unboxing of the sanyo
exactly cg10 i hope you guys like it and
i can't wait to get start filming with
this camera so thank you for watching
guys
peace